[Music]
in no loyalty news submitted by winter
is coming
I still haven't seen that [ __ ] show
you monsters coming - was it Game of
Thrones I have not seen one episode you
need to see a toe
I don't got cable you don't need it no
wait you talk about cable you know what
you got on each what else am I gonna
watch on there though there's so many
good shows you have to watch Westworld
Tiffany the sponsorships Wow I see
bootleggers yep
a man who fought off robbers to protect
his boss's money later stole 96 thousand
dollars for them that's [ __ ] he was
protecting his own money yeah would you
steal the money I'm gonna steal what if
he protected his boss from that money
but his boss was ungrateful a piece of
[ __ ] and he's like well you know what
you deserve to be robbed and in he ended
up jacket did you read this story no
because that's what I would do cuz
that's exactly what happened Wow really
yeah good guess David tell me about
Hawaii single minded that's so [ __ ]
crazy because you're nice and dark I got
burned as [ __ ] no I literally got burned
yeah your name your face is burnt Mariel
got burnt like a mother I want to know
though this is [ __ ] crazy like I
totally do that
yeah so this dude he so takes place in
India by the way that was a didgeridoo
with his mouth yeah dududu yes so this
dude he stole all right no so he's in
charge of taking the money to deposit at
the bank for his boss and so this one
time these robbers were trying to take
the money but he fought them off
successfully and returned the money to
his boss or like the walk or whatever
and then his boss so this dude he was
he's been having some tough time so he
has his boss like hey you know
can I get alone or you know like some
sort of reward for this all his boss
gave him was a freaking t-shirt what if
the t-shirt was his boss going employee
of the month t-shirt boss with two
thumbs up Indian so then that's when
this dude she was so upset you know
reasonably upset and he was talking to
his friend like you think you know why
at my posture he has me in charge of
depositing this I fought off these
robbers he couldn't give me nothing but
the freaking t-shirt so I'm gonna steal
the head so then that's when him and his
friend like he ended up giving his
friend a cut from the amount that he
stole and it's do you like he the friend
ended up pretty much riding out what
yeah what would he read him out because
the the employee he fled and the police
we were like asking around and he was he
got caught and he got grilled why do
people deserve something for doing the
right thing exactly that's what I was
thinking what is why deserve a stack
like dancing my dad would have yelled at
me for getting attacked like I should
have been more vigilant behind that you
should have been the first like you need
to always be looking you need to be
always be looking around anytime I might
they happen you'd be like well you
shouldn't have dad that happen to you
sure I think like you guys are right
like yeah why should you get a reward
for doing the right thing that's true
but in this situation it's like you know
it'd have been nice for the boss to give
him a little song he gave a t-shirt
that's poison no I mean like monitor
that is the definition of a little
something he has three daughters and
he's trying to get them married and so
like he could and then now all because I
forgot to mention he did have injuries
from fighting off the robbers and he had
to be bedridden oh that's the biggest
thing
okay that was it if someone protected my
you know like money like that I would at
least pay for like the recovery yeah
yeah I mean depending on the amount of
course I was assuming like if it was my
money
definitely give him a reward but I was
just you're just a better person it was
like I was [ __ ] taking a hundred
bucks to your grandma's house and I got
robbed and now I have a thousand dollar
[ __ ] Hospital exactly what I see the
extent of the injuries maybe you didn't
pay for his recovery because the family
members are doctors and [ __ ] what if
this free service and one of those guy
was trying to swindle him you know we
don't know it hurt all these people what
if he never actually did trying to get
robbed and he's making it up that's true
he never got robbed at all that's what I
would have done threw himself down a
flight of stairs so it looked like he
got robbed how much did this guy ask for
- uh I don't know you know how much
money was saved as well TIF answer the
question - I don't know right I think I
think he should rob him the amount of
how much he robbed I don't know how much
to do how much was it in Hawaii in
dollars for seashells I was transporting
somebody else's money I definitely
wouldn't give a [ __ ] about their money
yep hundred percent hey get away yeah
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] does your
money have to do with my life like not
just doing my job
like I was trying to live life go on
vacations with my my girlfriend go to
different places like maybe whoo I like
the I'm exhausted and [ __ ] look like you
belong in Hawaii right now thank you
with me vicariously trying to live
through him you've got like a Hawaiian
looking girlfriend why do you do that
you got your life why you look like you
could be local there am a hula danced
for 15 years the funny thing is if
people what that was what I did like
instead of playing a sport like I hula
into he's and danced and I used to tour
Hawaii I used to tour Hawaii great yeah
the funny thing is her mom grew up in
Hawaii she's white but she's the
Hawaiian local
that's Filipino but he's he's from LA
yeah he's from the lake he's the whole
yeah they all think that we're locals
and she's the outside yeah hula dance
yeah I want to see you too David did you
see any hula dancer while you're in
Hawaii absolutely I did not you did [ __ ]
to the [ __ ] turtles and dolphins
though how are you here we go-oh swam
with like 20 [ __ ] dollars now I can't
think of turtles without the one in her
that woman's vagina don't distract him
alright David tell we have wife boy it
was fantastic way so I with a lot of
[ __ ] dolphins within the Pali Coast
Incline oh yeah what did the mermaid
caves yes the mermaid caves it's I mean
this it's basically a cave that's dugout
towards like this rocky beach and so
light kind of comes through because
there's hold of the top okay and so it
kind of just illuminates the water to it
so it's like you have to get there
really early just because there's a lot
of [ __ ] white Instagram [ __ ] there
the mermaids right the [ __ ] mermaids
and then I I got in there and then right
when they came perfect I got to leave so
we got to take our photos before they
got in there before they're at flexing
and that 10:00 a.m. how the proposal go
I did not propose did not propose that's
a shame I had to show her why I like
Hawaii so much in the first place she
didn't get it shouldn't get the first
time you're saying next time that you go
to Hawaii before I go to Hawaii next
maybe she's just like okay okay David
yeah that's great
Hawaii sorry can I drop my keys once she
was like oh my god yeah drop my keys
slam your leg into a rock and you hit
one man then she's like oh my god really
it's really happening have you like
[ __ ] get a doctor
I believe he you [ __ ] cut back oh
yeah but Hawaii was super [ __ ] fun
man got really dark I mean I definitely
didn't travel to Hawaii like I normally
do because I think Mariel fees she's
like Ferdinand Magellan so she likes to
like explore like a [ __ ] so we
woke up like a 6 a.m. every day and just
start exploring you know it was cool but
then you know vacation bro 6 a.m. is not
a Vegas that like around like noon
closes like Hawaii but they don't isn't
so bad because it's like 9 o'clock here
yeah I mean for us because we just went
out tried a lot of different food I just
try to do everything possible and it was
fun like we swam in these like
underwater scooter things where we fed
fish and there was like turtle swimming
around us I love you know water scooters
dude so wait you have to be certified no
this one is just they're divers with you
and they put you in this like Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle villain robot and
then you have a bag of bread on you and
all these fish just [ __ ] swim around
you eat the food Wow yeah it's kind of
cool because you get to do this and the
bread comes out and you pet these fishy
they don't know what the [ __ ] you used
to do that in they used to do at Hanauma
Bay but then it [ __ ] with the
ecosystem the coral and the coral yeah
yeah no I I did something like that so I
went to Kauai with Cristina and went to
the Na Pali Coast where you go on his
boat along the coast you jump off the
snorkel and [ __ ] and then the ocean is
so crazy and kawaii it's just so country
that the waves and the winds right so
when I'm in there with a snorkel the
ocean is moving like this and I got
[ __ ] seasick snorkeling right in the
ocean and all these [ __ ] fishes came
swarming with all this food all they
cleaned it right up between it right I
have my GoPro
and you monetize when you went to the
Pali cook like the day we went to the
Napali coast if I ever wanted to propose
to somebody it should have been that day
because even the boat captain was like
this is probably one of the most perfect
days that I've ever done this trip on
David what are you waiting for and I
just sat there I guess Danny proposes is
gonna be like the shittiest day like
right when I bring the ring out of
[ __ ] rott logical and then walk away
with this big case kit that we did
remember with Burton Jia like every time
he was like in the worst moments like he
was taking a [ __ ] and he proposed or she
was taking a [ __ ] yeah we had like a
beach day tour we're on the west side of
Oahu and like the water was so [ __ ]
clear it was like 40 feet deep and you
could see the floor like that's how
clear Wow it was like it was [ __ ]
wild man like bunch of turtles oh it was
great man so you just got to go during a
[ __ ] hurricane to get the most
beautiful he actually did the first two
days it was a typhoon and then we just
made the most most of it we just walked
around on the rain I don't get [ __ ] you
they make the most of it 99% of it could
have been some more memories to it but I
hear ya it was cool though like I guess
what they considered cold is not cold to
us right cuz it was like 75 degrees and
raining and probably like shivering
great this feels [ __ ] good dude how's
the food David Waldron the food was
great Japanese food is great
like there's it's like the [ __ ] I mean
definitely it's all fat all meat all
carbs yeah so you know you get a little
fluffy there but you don't give a [ __ ]
but you're walking around a lot towns
when I'm swimming and whatever is the
closest thing to Japan yeah the food is
so [ __ ] good dude but that's because
they have a steady influx of Japanese
tourists so they have to keep the
quality like good because I think in LA
it's it's good but it's not quite there
there's something about it I don't know
I don't think the food was that great in
quiet when I Ono clients different
planets [ __ ] for all the old white
people not like wise different client
over food is Allah who so Allah who's
like the place the epicenter of like
food because a lot of like young Chefs
are going there they're innovating yeah
Allah who actually has a ton of like
world tourists Oh wha who is like the
Oh Hawaii exactly yeah anywhere where
there's just a bunch of seniors like
it's gonna be [ __ ] no-fault like
prunes and [ __ ] you know like it's kind
of ridiculous though because like I
don't know what it is but like let's say
you want to get like a salad just like
15 [ __ ] bucks
you know $15 salad I'm gonna get a $7
loco moco dude you know which is half
the price and twice the food so I said
[ __ ] salads dude yeah how do they do so
that's all tourist markup right yeah big
jucama in a discount if yeah and if
you're a local said oh I see it's not
gonna be the same though was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] we had like these matcha green tea
pancakes and that I had this thing that
was a mix between the Japanese omurice
at a local mocha put together that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] good so was like a beef
Danny Claus sauce over this like [ __ ]
medium patty scrambled eggs and fried
rice in the bottom feed what's up what's
up local Hong Kong a loco moco is
basically it's beef beef gravy hamburger
patty with an egg on top and then rice
or fried rice on the box and gravy gravy
like beef gravy or something this is
[ __ ] good dude it's like literally
like food that you either you hate
yourself after Hawaiian breakfast food
is so good
[Music]